So I'm going to give an update on some of the current strategies we are deploying in
treatment of CCUS that includes mostly a lot of investigator-initiated studies with
lisparicept and others.
These are my disclosures.
To just go over, you know, the clinical definition of CCUS means you have to have a WHO-defined
myeloid mutation with a VAF more than 2%.
The presence of cytopenias and the absence of or defining dysplasia for MDS.
CHIP progression is 1% per year, but CCUS progression is about 70% to 80% over a decade.
So the concept of early intervention in CCUS is stemming from two major goals.
One is improvement of clinically significant cytopenias.
And second is prevention of progression.
And as long as we are trying to get one of these two goals in the right patient population,
that would be okay.
Now, you know, this is known that clonal hematopoiesis is associated not just, and this is true for
CCUS as well, not just for a progression risk to myeloid malignancies, but a syndromic association
with a lot of inflammatory biological processes that are related to the presence of these mutations
other than a decreased risk of myeloid malignancies.
So this is known that clonal hematopoiesis is associated not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just for a progression risk to myeloid malignancies, but a syndromic association with a lot of inflammatory biological processes that are related to the presence of these mutations other than a decreased risk of myeloid malignancies.
So this is known that clonal hematopoiesis is associated not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, not just, and this is true for CCUS as well, but also for myeloid malignancies.
So the first question you really ask when you want to treat CCUS is how to risk stratify them, and I'm not going to go into details of all the strategies, but there are three current scores that we use, CHRS, myeloid neoplasm predict, and CCUS progression score, all of them have nuances, different ways that they decided that this is high risk or not, and, you know, briefly, if you sort of compare all of them, you'll see that they're all very similar.
The way I deal with this is I would really put, just for the sake of it, take a patient and put them into all of these risk scores, and just to make sure that they're not, there's nothing discrepant, but they generally work well.
You want to pick the right score for the right patient population, like TP53 mutated people probably do better with them and predict and things like that.
But the goal of these scoring is you do have a way to tell that these patients.
Are at high risk for progression. So these are the people who are going into these CCUS trials.
Now, if you think about treatment of CCUS, you know, other than clinically significant cytopenias where there's a logic, obviously, to treat them, and the second sort of goal of progression is based on, okay, what are the mechanisms of progression that you can actually target?
So inflammation, it's known that inflammation.
Inflammatory signaling worsens clonal hematopoiesis.
Many people have done great work with models that if you inhibit inflammation, you decrease the clone size.
So inflammation is a way to target.
Aging, we haven't had a holy grail, kombucha juice does not work.
So we can't really stop aging at this moment, but obviously that's a process that has been a big question.
Term line predisposition.
Will will also be important, but again, you cannot really change it and obviously, just like, you know, Dr.
Behar was saying external pressure and avoiding sort of the pressures that lead to a growth in a clone size.
So these are all the reason all these places that you can use to to target.
And here's a list of ongoing trials in CCUS that is going through and I'll go through one of the all of them.
Canakinumab for high risk CCUS with the primary endpoint for.
Aggression free survival.
This is a randomized blinded study, which is currently ongoing.
Umabarati is the PI.
This trial is open at Cornell and we are enrolling as well.
We are also enrolling patients into loose paracept with the goal of improvement in cytopenias.
The IDH mutated CCUS, there are a couple of trials ongoing led by Kelly Bolton.
And Dr.
Chin with again the goal of improvement of cytopenias, ascorbic acid, statins and metformin.
These are more targeting the the metabolism way.
So let's see what what I'll focus on some of these trials that we are involved in.
So if we think about targeting inflammation, the, you know, IL-1 beta axis was is deemed important mice models of
the clinical trial.
So we're going to focus on the clinical trial.
And then we're going to focus on the clinical trial.